oh
is
i know that you can't love me
we're still getting by the way
forever
so
yes
oh
nobody yeah
huh
there's no
forever
today
can't you see if
i think so many ways
hi everybody
myself
they could have made you
girl you're my reality
you're the person
okay
um
uh
then
is
me
yep
i don't know what is
one already
again
um
three
so
my
220.
um
i mean that this is one hour what about
five minutes
oh
it was an yeah yeah
so
foreign
the roses in the window on
is
if i don't change the pace
in my hands
i wonder if those changes
have left the sky
foreign
in my hands
so
hello
in my head
uh
oh
baby
muscles
now
please
mr
hey
all right
macho baby
oh
everyday
and
hey
thank you
millionaires
who will they send you down
oh
hear me
and it seems to me
but i was just
legendary
superstar
and it seems to me
is
yes
already
road
you lived your life
i love you
that's what i'm trapping yes we're good
we'll find out when he arrives
yes
in times when we don't know
when we lose
to place
give us
a sense
watch us
just like every child
give us
is
oh
deuteronomy just before dawn
if you were silence you
announces the cat who can now be reborn
and come back to a different
evangelical life
foreign
okay
turn your face
open up
the meaning of what happens
so
i get in this one
and a new day
raining
is
if you touch me
you'll understand
is
bye
me
nine o'clock on a saturday
a regular crowd shuffles in
there's an old man sitting next to me
making love to his tonic engine
he says son can you play me a memory
i'm not really sure how it goes
but it's sad and it's sweet and i knew
it complete
when i was
oh us
a song you're the piano man
sing us a song tonight
while we're all in the mood for a melody
you've got us feeling all right
now john at the bar is a friend of mine
he gets me
but there's some place that he'd rather
be
he says bill i believe this is killing
me
as a smile ran away from his face well
i'm sure that i
could be a movie star if i could get out
of this
who never had time for a while
and he's talking with david who's still
in the navy
and probably will be
and the waitress is practicing politics
as the businessmen slowly get stoned
yes they're sharing a drink they call
loneliness
but it's better than drinking
sing us a song you're the piano man
sing us a song tonight
well we're all in the mood for a melody
and you've got us feeling all right
it's a pretty good crowd for a saturday
and the manager gives me a smile
cause he knows that it's me they've been
coming to see
to forget about life for a while
what are you doing here
us feeling all right
adding this product
oh lord
hold on
and
but i don't know who i am
it's
oh
the last time
is
me
i
oh
how long will he take
bye
i know this can't be right hey
baby come on
you want that for me
for you in the game
that life would be much better
is
right check one two one two testing
testing one two one two
one two one two
testing one two one
two one two
testing my check hey
you guys good
my check one two one two one two
one two one two all right
here
hey you guys there's anything that
it was a little means
hey jenna how you
all doing all your audios everything
it's good to go
are you ready to do this together
oh
to open boys
you can't let me
oh
beyonce
what do you think you'll do then
just
today
let's do this
oh
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats as the program will begin
momentarily
this
mean
dreams
people always told me be careful what to
do
she
lands
just remember to always
don't dance
young girls behind me
she's a
is
my son
oh
cheese
huh
oh
wow
uh
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats as the program will begin
momentarily
is this the real life
is this just fantasy
open your eyes
look up to the skies
little
to
me
all the way
my mom
if i'm
yourself
too late my time is
goodbye everybody
i've got to go
gotta leave you all behind me
sometimes
nobody
is
let him go
me
just gotta right
hey
it ain't me
but when the tax man
let me yeah
oh
no
there is
i would
my
everybody
is
oh mother tell your children
not to do
rise in sun
the black one
to wear
tape
i know i'm one
um
foreign
she was more like the beauty
she told me
be careful
young girls
be careful what to do
yes
she says
uh
oh
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
donald j trump
who gave
well thank you very much and i'm
thrilled to be back at the historic
jupiter inlet i know it very well don't
live very far away as you know
the lighthouse it's uh my home state is
called the state of florida it's a great
state
hello ed sit down do you have seats yeah
you do sit down everybody
sunshine state is truly one of the most
beautiful places on earth i love it
and together we will preserve its
breathtaking natural splendor for
generations to come we're here today to
celebrate our incredible record of
natural conservation and
environmental protection over the last
four years i've been working with
you're both governors your last
governors your current governor is
fantastic by the way and we've been
working very very hard we've been
working very hard together to make sure
everything is perfect
and to recommit ourselves to preserving
the awesome majesty of god's
great creation joining us in the
wonderful support effort of that mission
is secretary of the interior man who's
worked so hard on this david bernhardt
thank you very much david
thank you an epa administrator very
powerful man
when he says you can do it you do it
when he says you can't it's over with
you don't have a chance
andrew wheeler thank you andrew thank
you great job
and of course you governor ron desantis
who's run not only did he run a great
campaign he's
a great governor thanks ron what a great
job
what a great job he did of course we'll
let you know on november 3rd
i'll let you know he did a good job
also i want to introduce lieutenant
governor jeanette
nunez who's been such a fantastic friend
and
supporter thank you very much jeanette
and one of the great attorney generals
anywhere in the country
ashley moody ashley thank you thank you
very much
florida cfo jimmy patronis
jimmy thank you jimmy great job
a man who everybody loves he's highly
respected in washington he's a great
senator
lindsey graham south carolina thank you
lindsey
great job representatives
gruss bilrakis where's gus
gus how are you gus thank you very much
great job you're doing
we have a lot of good ones here we have
warriors i call them my warriors that's
what they are
and gus the job you've done and matt
gates where's matt
where's matt where's matt
that's not a very good location for you
man that's
i'm used to having you sitting right up
here what's going on
that's good matt gates brian mast
brian fantastic guy thank you brian
they are all warriors you see what they
do they have to fight pelosi
schumer to have to fight all these
characters and they do very well in the
fights we want him on our side
greg stoopy greg thank you very much
great job
great job this morning i watched bill
posey
bill bill posey thank you bill
michael waltz michael
fantastic michael and ted yoho they've
actually become my friends actually
ted thank you very much great great
where's ted
great ted thank you very much great job
and from south carolina state
representative nancy mace
who's got a very important race where i
think you're doing very well
i think you're doing very well from what
i hear right you got to win that one
that's an important one
we're behind you a thousand percent you
know that right
as well as mayor of miami-dade county
carlos jimenez where is carlos
carlos great i want to thank you all for
being here my administration's proving
every day that we can
improve our environment while creating
millions of high-paying jobs
this is a really sharp contrast to the
extreme
radical left that you've had to deal
with and
what you're doing right now is a lot
better than anything you've ever been
accustomed to i will tell you that
joe biden's plan would destroy america's
middle class while giving a free pass
to the world's worst foreign polluters
like china russia
india and many others they don't have to
clean up their lands
but we have to clean up ours the left's
agenda isn't about protecting the
environment it's about punishing america
and that's true
instead of focusing on radical ideology
my administration is focused on
delivering real results and that's what
we have and we right now have the
cleanest air
we've ever had in this country let's say
over the last 40 years
because i assumed 200 years ago was
probably better what do you think
i would say that what do you think
fellas
so i do want to preface that because the
fake news is back there
when i say the cleanest air we've ever
had over a 40-year period lindsey is
that okay
a couple of hundred years ago i would
imagine it was pretty good
to safeguard our stunning coastal areas
i signed legislation
authorizing 100 million dollars to fight
the red tide and toxic algae
and to preserve the everglades and
defend florida
from catastrophic flooding you know
about the flooding
we spent a lot of money on flooding and
a lot of money on hurricanes and
when your governors came to me and they
said can we have this can we have that
we need some more for the panhandle they
said we have to help the panhandle i
said
without question and without any weight
let's go right that's what we said
you've never had it so easy in your life
he'd walk into my office say sir just
one more how much is it going to cost
how about an extra billion
yeah my staff wasn't too thrilled that's
we had to override the staff a couple of
times
we've directed over a half a billion
dollars to fix the
herbert hoover dike and lake okeechobee
lake okeechobee we fixed it up good mr
mayor we did a good job
did a good job we will now compete with
this
uh project and we're way ahead you know
we are
way ahead about three years i think
ahead of schedule from what the original
time of completion was going to be
and i'm in particular happy with what
we've done on lake
okeechobee i know it well i know it well
everyone said that one couldn't be done
ron you know that right they said it
would never happen you'll never get it
funded it's a big deal and
it's all gotten done including uh
the tide is gone which will be gone
finally
from uh all of the problems that they've
had with it
we've expanded funding for the
everglades restoration by over
55 compared to four years ago
and i also want to thank the army corps
of engineers for their vital work on the
c-44 reservoir
and the help they are unbelievable one
thing when they build it
i said you know you could buy you could
do it a little bit less expensive than
that
the walls don't have to be seven feet
thick they could be
like two feet thick but you know when
the army corps of engineers do it they
do it right that's one thing i can tell
you
we're building the wall the wall along
mexico between mexico and the united
states we're over 300 miles now of wall
and that's a serious wall that's a world
that's meant to last
and meant to work but that'll help
revitalize the wetlands in the st
lucie river estuary and the indian river
lagoon
whoa that's pretty good
we hit home with that one huh but today
i have a very
important announcement i don't know if
it's bigger than the things we just
announced and the things that we've
already done or we're in the process of
completing
in a few moments i will sign a
presidential order extending the
moratorium
on offshore drilling on florida's gulf
coast
and expanding it to florida's atlantic
coast as well as the coasts
of georgia and south carolina
thank you very much everybody thank you
thank you thank you very much i guess
you like that one the best of all
this action follows close consultation
with florida governor ron desantis he's
been unbelievable
florida senators marco rubio and rick
scott they've worked so hard
as well as south carolina senator
lindsey graham and tim scott
lindsay thank you lindsay liked the idea
right from the beginning i said what do
you think it took you how long about two
seconds to say i like it
the governor of south carolina a great
man and a really great governor henry
mcmaster
and i also want to thank the governor of
georgia brian
kemp he's doing a fantastic job
and a senator who from the day one from
day one he's been with me
senator david perdue georgia and senator
kelly lafleur
and congressman doug collins and south
carolina state representative nancy mace
again i want to thank you all credible
thanks to my administration's
pro-american energy policies
we can take this step and the next step
while remaining the number one producer
of
oil and natural gas anywhere in the
world we're the largest producer now in
the world
by far we're number one in the world and
we are energy independent which is a
nice
with fracking the shale revolution
and the tremendous surge in american
energy production we're showing that
we can create jobs safeguard the
environment and keep energy prices low
for america and low for
our citizens and you see that you also
see it
when you pump the gas into your car and
you're paying sometimes a lot less than
two dollars lately right
so we're doing well and we have so much
of it i don't know
we got more than everybody anybody ever
thought possible right
really incredible what's happened the
approach of joe biden
and the radical left is exactly the
opposite their policies will destroy
jobs cause energy prices to double and
triple and quadruple to skyrocket beyond
belief
and the environment will be badly hurt
if you go by that
badly badly hurt it'll be injured and
permanently injured
and very importantly they'll take away
our energy independence
and they'll do it quickly and they won't
even know what happened to them
we're dealing with some smart customers
they know exactly
what to do and they don't like it when
we're energy independent
they don't like it at all so it's been a
really uh
amazing thing for florida from the
environmental standpoint
and i have to tell you from the energy
standpoint
and from a uh very important
level of cost you're at a level of cost
now with your electric
and with so many other things caused and
created by energy and fuel
the likes of which you haven't seen in
30 years as president i'll defend our
environment i'll defend our workers and
our cherished way of
life last month i signed the great
american outdoors act
the most significant investment in our
national parks
in over a century since teddy roosevelt
penny roosevelt you know they came to my
office a lot of the senators that i just
introduced and ron and
everybody they came to my office they
said that
this will make us and make you the
number one
environmental president since teddy
roosevelt
i said huh that sounds good because i
wasn't going to do it i figured you know
let's not do it
but when they said that that was like a
challenge so i said well
why does it only have to go back to
teddy roosevelt which is over 100 years
why can't we say from george washington
right from the beginning they said well
we're not quite there yet but one other
bill like this will be there lindsay you
know that right
but it's true number one since teddy
roosevelt who would have thought trump
is the great environmentalist you hear
that ed
do you hear that
that's good and i am i am i believe
strongly in it through this legislation
we're providing nearly
10 billion dollars for long delayed
maintenance projects in our
national parks and florida has helped as
much as anybody and maybe more
my administration is fully or partially
cleaned up 61 epa
superfund pollution sites that were
rotting all over our country
far more than obama and biden no matter
how far you go back more than
any administration since my inauguration
we've recovered more
endangered or threatened species than
any other administration has
accomplished
in its first term earlier this year i
announced that the united states would
join the 1 trillion trees initiative
we already have 1 billion trees pledged
to be planted and is moving very rapidly
we've opened land and expanded access
over 4 million acres of public lands
for hunting and fishing including over
000 acres in florida my sons would be
very happy to hear that
as the last administration pursued its
globalist agenda abroad
they were all over the place they were
everywhere but here
in our country they were taking care of
other lands you countries that you never
heard of they were taking care of
and they didn't do a good job there
either they neglected the fundamentals
of public health
right here in the united states right
here in our home
my administration is focused on ensuring
crystal clean air and water under my
administration we've seen a significant
drop in air pollution
since 2017 a very significant drop for
the first time
in nearly 30 years we are strengthening
standards to prevent
vulnerable children from being exposed
to lead and copper and drinking water
including in our schools they were
exposed to
lead and copper in drinking water we've
done some job with that that was an
important one
and we've invested over 38 billion
dollars in drinking water infrastructure
to care for our children
i'm committed to ensuring the united
states has the cleanest air and cleanest
water on earth
the contrast between our vision and the
radical left has never been more clear
they talk a big game and they do nothing
that's really what it is too they talk
and talk the environment they talk and
talk
nothing happens it's all talk
it's all words and no action you ever
hear that to our political opponents
environmental policy is just an excuse
to advance a
socialist platform that will impose
trillions and trillions of dollars in
new taxes
and send our jobs overseas making it
impossible
to open up new companies and to live
less expensively your energy costs would
be four or five
sometimes even under scenarios ten times
more expensive
and really you wouldn't even have energy
to my administration
environmental protection is a sacred
obligation and so it is our duty to
fight for the dreams and livelihoods of
the citizens we serve
and to the citizens of florida that i
know so well and that i love this is my
home
this is my home
we're rapidly restoring the greatest
economy in history
we created the greatest economy in the
history of our country
and then we had it close it up when the
china plague came
in we closed it up we saved millions of
lives
we banned highly infected china from
coming in it was highly infected
the people were highly infected wuhan
province
we banned them nobody said do it
everybody said i shouldn't do it biden
said don't do it
three months later he admitted i was
right but we banned
people we would have lost hundreds of
thousands more but we would have lost
millions if we didn't close it up and
now we open it up
and we're setting records at every
single level
so we're maintaining that pristine
resource of beautiful clean
environment at every single community in
florida and all over the country
we'll always defend the everglades and
we will always safeguard the magnificent
florida coastline
we'll expand access for fishermen and
sportsmen
we'll uphold your right to hunt and we
will protect
your right to keep and bear arms your
second amendment
and i can tell you this if joe biden
gets in
he'll have no nothing to say about it
he's not
let's face it joe's shot if joe biden
gets in
your second amendment is gone it's gone
either obliterated to a point of being
gone or gone itself
okay it you will not have a second
amendment and the pressure put on me in
the last four years
to make massive changes to the second
amendment
which would have really rendered it
worthless
uh ron knows ron knows
the pressure put on me uh very few
people would have been able to withstand
that pressure they would have made big
big cuts and big changes
your second amendment will remain
powerful will
remain strong will remain with you
we will reassure our critical supply
chains and we will bring back jobs and
factories from china and other foreign
polluters
and everything we do will be guided by
our love of this state its people and
its priceless
natural treasures it's a great state
from its breathtaking beaches to a
shimmering base from its vast marches
all those beautiful marshes marshlands
to its wildfires there is truly no place
on earth like the great state of florida
and i i can tell you i am so happy to
have helped because when i
was first elected you had things that
were in such bad shape
and now they're fixed or being fixed at
a cost of a lot of money
but they're either fixed or being fixed
and soon they'll be in better condition
than they were the day they were built
which was many many decades ago
we have things that were built a long
time ago that were in a state of
disrepair that you wouldn't believe
as long as i'm president of the united
states we will conserve this wondrous
national inheritance from key west to
keep his cane
from tampa to tallahassee from the
pensacola beautiful pensacola i love
pensacola
i think it was 97 that's one of the
reasons i like it
they say how'd you do in pennsylvan
pensacola i said was that maybe
95 97 and right up there so that helps
it's amazing how that can help isn't it
right here to
jupiter which i know very well will
preserve this glorious land for our
children
for our grandchildren and for every
generation of american to come
and i will now sign this order
it's an order that does so much for the
state of florida it's an order that i'm
so proud to sign
i've been talking about this with ron
and with
all of all of the people i've mentioned
for a long time
and i said we want to get it done and
this protects your
your beautiful gulf and your beautiful
ocean and it will for a long time to
come so
congratulations to florida and georgia
and south carolina and frankly north
carolina
but i want to just uh thank everybody
for being here and this is a
honor for me to sign this order thank
you very much
so
wow
oh
there's a place you can go
and i'm sure you will find many ways
you can make feel your dreams but you've
got
to know this one thing
no man does it all by himself
put your pride on the shelf and just go
there
it's funny
foreign
i was once in your shoes i said i was
down